Bor if you wouldn't mind rising and join
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America the
Republic for which it stands one nation
and you got an intern I want an intern
intern I want an intern
oh morning
turns waiting for Jennifer cuz what's
this
that's
yeah yeah yeah I didn't know either when
I saw him I was like hey who are you
guys
that I'm opening the executive session
on House Bill
59 relative to the assault on a
firefighter emergency medical care
provider and I
recognize representative PR to introduce
an
amendment good morning uh I introduce
thank
you
uh 2025
d0
that have a copy of that right we don't
have a no I just had a stack stand by
while we locate the stack of amendments
that they're on the table
oh
so I have three 159's on my desk you
have 59 there yeah yeah I do I handed
you
my9 okay the motion has been
made second and seconded uh
representative appr would you like to
speak to your
motion you don't have on the changes on
the
amendment so are we elely go with the
amendment the amendment moves the word
reckless out of the original
bill you like to speak to your
second uh thank you Mr chairman um I
would just say that we heard during
testimony we heard from um several
people that do this as as their career
and I don't think that
anybody that anybody is doing anything
that's crossing the line I don't believe
that anybody is intentionally putting
anybody's um you know mental health at
stake here and I believe that it that
it's time that we uh listen to the
constituents thank you I would add as
far as the amendment goes we we heard
from um we heard from the mental health
community and I recognize their concerns
and the so did the sponsor and after
own yeah you might want to move to the
front then because I'm not going to I'm
not going to yell um your mic pull to
the the the
um in any event we spoke to the mental
health community and as a result we
amended this to take the word recklessly
out of it so that someone couldn't
necessarily be charged for an action
that they might not be responsible for
due to a mental health
situation with that further
discussion seeing none ask the clerk to
call the role the motion on the floor is
to adopt the amendment hang on
Pro
okay
yes uh representative Boyd yes
representative
devoid yes representative morency yes
La yes representative saborn D schir yes
representative valerino yes
representative Harry a no representative
muse no representative
Newman no representative Murphy
no the clerk votes no representative
Newell no representative Southworth no
chairman Roy chal yes 97 97 the
amendment is adopted I recognize
representative approve for a
motion I move o to pass as amended
second
Vice chair rhods yes representative
PR yes representative Boyd yes
representative devoid yes representative
morency yes representative La yes
representative saor D Shir yes
representative valerino yes
representative Harry Gite no
representative news no representative
Newman no representative Murphy no the
clerk votes no representative Newell no
representative Southworth no chairman
Roy
chairs 97 97 the motion is
adopted um I need the reports today
please before you
session really
I here I open the executive session on
house
bill9 relating to mental health firearms
and I recognize myself to make a
motion I
move
amendment
number
H this amendment to the
bill oh yeah I need a
second sure second seconded on the
amendment thank you um this amendment to
the bill was done after speaking with
the National Rifle Association and
several other Pro Second Amendment
groups who agreed with the concept that
um after all the NRA did invent Nicks um
that we report mental health prohibitors
to Nicks um however what they were
concerned with is a confiscation piece
so the entire confiscation piece has
been left out and taken out now the
judge will just advise someone who has
been so restricted that they have to
dispose of their firearms if they have
any um so otherwise the bill is the
same and I'm open for further discussion
on the bill on the
that is this the same amendment that you
introduced when you introduced the bill
I I don't believe so I believe this is a
a further Amendment this was this is one
that I got after that date is
0328 this is 0487
H you passed it out
right okay yeah and I and I don't
believe we received copies of the new
to the clerk says she's handing them out
y again again it it just it takes out
the confiscation
piece otherwise the bill is identical
piece any further discussion on the
amendment seeing none i' ask clerk to
call the role the motion is to adopt the
amendment Vice chair roads no
representative
Pro cautiously yes representative boy no
representative Dev void no
representative
morency yes representative La no
Representative saor dniir no
representative valerino yes
representative Harry goth yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Southworth yes
chairman Roy chair yes 115 115 the
motion is made I mean the amendment is
adopted I recognize myself for a motion
to ought to pass with
Amendment and I need a second second
second
who seconded then okay representative
here gath right um I don't believe we
need any further discussion unless
someone has something else they'd like
to
add
representative chairman Roy I've
received more emails asking for this
bill to be opposed than any other bill
on our docket today um I don't know if
the public is completely on our side on
this one sir thank you I I would suggest
that those emails um are the result of
very strong campaign by several local
gun uh groups to get people to oppose it
however if you read the emails and I
have done so they they claim a false
thing they claim that this is a red flag
bill which is and they claim that it it
denies due process the bill is neither
um a red red flag bill is when someone
makes an allegation against somebody
that they may be dangerous and based on
that allegation the police go and take
their their
firearms this bill someone has to
actually be brought to the court first
proved that they are dangerous to
themselves or others in a court of law
when they have an attorney and only
after then can they be banned from
wanning Firearms so that the difference
between a red flag Bill and this are
night and day um this bill is the same
as is the law in 48 other states whereas
I think only 14 States or 20 States may
have a red flag law so there's there's a
big difference between the two so that's
that's my answer to the emails any
further
discussion seeing none I'd ask cler to
call the role the motion is ought to
pass with Amendment Vice chair roads no
Representative
appr no representative Boyd no
Representative deid no representative
morency yes representative l no
representative saborn D Shir no
representative Valerie
yes representative Harry cther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Southworth yes
chairman
Roy chotot yes 106 106 motion carries um
anyone who's doing a would like to do a
um report against yes sir okay
if you could by the end of the day end
of the day yes sir thank you um 124 what
124 124 12
106 okay that I close the executive
session and I open well I lost my
sheet I open the executive session on
House Bill
592 and I recognize myself for a
motion and the motion is to adopt
seconded this
bill and the
amendment fine-tune
the
bail position based on what we received
for input from the governor's office the
chief executive who's in charge of
enforcing the laws in our
state has asked us to tighten these we
have heard from the people of Manchester
that they request that our bail bills be
tightened that too many people were
getting out whether or not that is the
case is the public perception that it is
um I've seen arguments both ways uh
questions were raised about the recent
um knife attack in Manchester if you
look into it it's really difficult to
tell who should have U been arrested who
should have been charged and who should
have been let go in that case with two
people fighting wedding the police at
the time did not argue against his
release the judge who looked at the case
the next Monday did not feel that he
should be held and then on
appeal um to a superior court judge he
didn't feel that the person should be
held so that was a bad case to to argue
for this but there are other cases that
are not quite so debatable there people
have been let go so this is what we're
going to go forward with today is the
amendment that's going to be considered
and I would ask you to support it would
you like to speak to your
second no thank you Mr chairman great
job further
Muse I would like to point out that the
that the one uh incident that's been
used as really the primary driver uh for
this bill has not even gone to trial yet
um we are basically making a decision on
changing New Hampshire law based on
incremental reporting um of varying
quality by different news organizations
um which is not the way we should be
doing things in the New Hampshire house
speaking to the amendment itself it
makes some substantial changes to bail
policy that only took effect on the 1st
of January um the bottom line is it's
extremely rare uh even in circumstances
like the ones that we're in now where in
February uh we're making changes of a
laot to a law that just took effect in
at the on the 1 of January so um
unfortunately unlike last year we just
haven't been able to slow down this
process and really take a careful
well-considered look and as a result we
have some things that are baked into
this amendment that I I think are
substantial changes that a lot of folks
are not going to agree with so for
instance in this in this amendment under
under this amendment uh people will be
able to be held for 36 hours instead of
24 hours uh without a hearing uh they'll
be able to be held over the weekend and
it won't count against those 32 hours so
instead of including time spent over the
weekend it actually this amendment
actually excludes that time the other
thing that this amendment does is it
changes the standard of evidence from
clear and convincing evidence uh to
probable cause so prob cause is the same
standard of evidence uh that police
officers use to arrest people so
actually having uh in statute the
ability to hold People based on no
information that it took to arrest them
um why do we even have judges for why do
we have people who were involved in this
process the bottom line is there are
always changes and tweaks that we can
make to our laws uh but those changes
and tweaks should be well considered and
they shouldn't be uh the product of a
pitchfork and torches process which this
has been thank
you thank you for the
discussion seeing none oh representative
Murray thank you Mr chair um yeah I just
want to uplift everything my colleague
just said I think um he hit it right on
the nose it is disappointing to have
spent so much time really carefully
making um adjustments to our bail
process that haven't been given the time
of day um to you know fully work or or
not work yet and I would have been happy
to make further adjustments carefully
and with time and it's unfortunate that
um this is being rushed through for um
other reasons um and I just wanted to St
as a resident and representative
Manchester I have had constituents ask
me to vote against this not everyone in
Manchester feels like this is a problem
and in fact a lot of people do think
that um changing the bail law like this
is going to um risk violating people's
constitutional rights and there are
concerns about that so I will be voting
against this amendment um I think we did
a lot of really good and intentional
work over the past two years as a
committee and like I said I would be
happy to continue it further I just
don't believe rushing through this bill
right now when we haven't even given um
time for the changes we made to already
play out doesn't make
sense thank you um for the for the
record I just want to note the the
36-hour piece this applies only to
people that commit those crimes that are
on the list that we sent in last year
that could not be heard by uh bail
Commissioners otherwise the vast
majority of cases will be hurled by bail
Commissioners and people will be
released promptly or decisions made to
hold them promptly this 36-hour piece
only applies to those charged with the
most serious
crimes um further
discussions see none I ask C to call the
RO the motion the floor is ought to um
amend to adopt the amendment Vice chair
roads yes representative PR yes
representative Boy Yes representative
devoid yes representative morency yes
representative La yes representative
saor D Shir yes representative valerino
yes representative harri a no
representative
Muse representative Newman no
representative Murphy no the clerk votes
no representative Newell no
representative Southworth no chairman
Roy chair votes yes 97 97 a motion um to
adopt the amendment is passed the
amendment is adopted I recognize myself
for a motion ought to pass with
Amendment second second seconded by
representative
rhods um any further anyone wish further
discussion I think we've covered our
differences on this already see none I'd
ask the cour to call the RO the motion
is out to pass with amendment by chair
roads yes representative PR yes
representative Boyd yes representative
devoid yes representative morency yes
representative L yes representative
saborn duir yes representative valerino
yes representative harri goth no
representative
muse no representative Newman no
representative Murphy no the clerk votes
no representative newel no
representative Southworth no chairman
Roy chair votes yes 97 97 the motion
carries the bill was adopted who's going
to write The Minority Report I will the
minority will also be a minority
Amendment okay uh wait a minute you want
it you mean on the floor you're going to
do what's that you're going to do a
you
okay I don't know what that is I don't
know with that the executive session is
closed
what it what what you want
e